hello freak people are really
reluctant to give up fun like lying
and driving their car fast it fills two
things people are going to have a hard
time with you like actually getting into
the into their mind seeing their actual
mind and being able to do that so we can
know without a doubt whether or not
someone's guilty or innocent but my
question to you is if you could get
inside someone's mind and it was like
that really super um suggestive guy they
were talking about earlier that just
confessed all the horrific demonic
possession stuff and eating babies what
if it's like getting to the - that guy's
mind what if you can't tell well that
the case that that worries me and this
is perhaps an inept segue to politics
but the me we're in people's minds
everybody get you get someone talking
long enough you know their minds I mean
they can only conceal what they're about
only so well right how do you can cuz
you're a super smart wizard but I've no
just but Jamie I don't know about I
don't know if he's a mind reader but the
question is will people care you know
it's like like if you if you have we
don't even need a lie detector if you
have someone who's openly lying right
right who just gets caught in lies again
and again you can see it - you feel it
right but people don't seem to care
right in the in the Lisa in a political
process I'm thinking in this case of
Trump where you have someone who is in
in some cases lying or just changing his
mind in such a incoherent way that it's
the functional equivalent of line I mean
someone who becomes totally
unpredictable he has a stance that is
aid on Tuesday and it's be on Wednesday
and when the discrepancy is pointed out
he tells you to go yourself right
so it's just there's just no a there is
no accountability to his his own states
of consciousness right that he's going
to be helped to and the people who love
Him don't seem to care they actually in
as far as I can tell I don't know
someone
these people personally but it is from
based on you know social media and
seeing the few articles where someone
has explained why they love Trump people
view this as a kind of this sort of this
dishonesty what is on in my view both
dishonesty and a kind of theatrical
hucksterism a sort of person who's who's
pretending to be many things that he
probably isn't they see it as a new kind
of authenticity right like this guy he's
just letting it rip he doesn't care what
it what is true he doesn't care what
your expectations for coherence are he's
just going to tell you to yourself
every which way and this is the new way
of being honest right this is a new form
of ntek integrity it's amazing to watch
mist it's getting it's been I'm someone
who actually I remember on my own
podcast I I think I was talking to Paul
bloom this is Yale psychologist who's
great and we had talked we got into
politics so this is at least a year ago
but at that point I said there's no way
we're gonna be talking about Trump in a
year and this is going to completely
flame out and I was this is a I don't
tend to make predictions but this was a
clear moment that I remember of making a
prediction which is now obviously false
but I just couldn't imagine that this
was this what people were going to find
this compelling enough to further for
him to be on the on the cusp of getting
elected it's it is terrifying have you
taught if you talked this issue to death
on your podcast or I guess we kind of
have well I think this is how everybody
feels everybody feels like you're
supposed to be like with their person
whether it's Bernie or whether it's for
Hillary or whether you're a trump
supporter whatever it is like you have
to be all but like if you look at the
the choices that were given the none of
these could really be described as ideal
no no like Hillary Clinton you could
want a woman in the White House and you
wanna want to show everyone that a woman
could do that job just as well as a man
she's got the most experience she
certainly has the most experience
dealing with foreign governments and she
certainly has the most experience in
politics can make it easier but she's
also involved in two criminal
investigations she had a
the observer in her bathroom there's all
squirrely stuff going on she's terrible
anyways she was anti-gay marriage
okay like 2013 and then wouldn't admit
the change of mind other yeah it's a
she's a politician she's probably a
brilliant woman but she's also set in
her ways
in a politician and a politician to the
end and part of being a politician is
being a huckster you got to be
able to get those people to see your
side and the way you do that is to talk
like this I can't talk like a normal
person needs a speech coach so they all
do he's terrible to the Trump's not even
good at it and he kicks their asses well
no but no but her boys she has a kind of
to use the the sexist trope she has a
shrill for it we know where when you get
her in front of a mic and there's a
crowd and she thinks she's talking over
the crowd which she doesn't have to do
because she's in front of a mic the
sound you get is just it's is she's
yelling when she doesn't need to yell
someone someone has to teach her how to
dial that back what you just is called
mansplaining yes I'm Harry I'm
explaining to the men in her future talk
some sense into her but she she is she's
a bad she's a bad candidate right I have
no doubt that she's very smart and she's
well-informed and she's qualified and
she is absolutely who I will vote for
given the choices but you know I totally
understand people's reservations with
her she's a liar she's an opportunist
she is just almost preternatural e
inauthentic I mean she's just like she
will just focus group every third
sentence and you feel that from her
right and and this is all true and yet I
also believe the people who say I've
never met her but people who know her
and have met her say that behind closed
doors you know one on one she's
incredibly impressive and and great but
that doesn't translate into her
candidacy she said probably think she
has to do it old-school you know I mean
the way she's doing it but she I mean
the thing is she's when you look at the
what's work what worries me so I went
out on Facebook the other day
and I have said very little about this
but I've made enough noises of the sort
that I just made that people understand
that I that I'm you know for Clinton
despite all my reservations about her
and when I got on my own Facebook page
which you have to assume is filtered by
the people who are following me on
Facebook and and already like me in some
sense just like a thousand comments of
pure pain I mean no one loves Hillary no
one no one said oh thank god someone
someone smartest for Hillary it was all
just Bernie people and Trump people
flaming me for for for the the most
tepid possible endorsement of Clinton
all I said was listen I understand you
know Clinton's a liar and she's and
she's an opportunist and she's I
completely get your reservations about
her but at least she's a grown-up right
and she's going to be the candidate it's
not going to be Sanders pessoa the
moment now is the moment to put your
political idealism behind you if you're
a Sanders person and recognize that
there is a vast difference between
Clinton and Trump and no she's not going
to change the system but she's also not
going to run civilization off a cliff
right and I didn't forget how I said it
on Facebook but it was just the most it
was just it really was a lesser of two
evils argument and it just it was um
it's amazing to see how energized and
passionate people are in defensive Trump
and Sanders and there's almost none of
that for Clinton it's like if people are
just sheepishly saying that just
divulging that they will vote for
Clinton but they are maybe somewhere
that I haven't noticed someone look
absolutely loves Clinton but it's just
it's she does not have her defenders the
way these guys do have you seen the man
enough to vote for her campaign no no
it's with like hipster dudes with
tattoos and beards that are gonna vote
for Hillary No I hope it's fake cuz it's
so brilliant I hope it's not real is it
fake thank God is it thank god it's so
good though cuz it's not that fake it's
pretty good like you could almost see
so wait a minute yes I mean this is not
that for her right this is no no no it's
not bad for it's just funny that someone
would like make a joke
political ad you know that you have to
be man enough to vote for Hillary like
there's guys out there that would buy
that they would they would I'm gonna
know bro they'd do it it's a scary time
because it doesn't seem like anybody
that you would want to be president
wants to be President and so we're left
with all right what do you pick it's
like as if we're going to play the Super
Bowl with three the shittiest teams we
could find we're just gonna go get some
drunk high school kids go get some
inmates with club feet we're just gonna
throw whoever it we're gonna may have
the worst game ever and that's what this
game is is not a good game this is not a
game where you've got like a John F
Kennedy versus a Lyndon Johnson or it's
not it's not like like powerful
characters its Trump I guess is a really
powerful character but in more ways like
a showman character yeah like what what
he's doing he's like he's putting on a
great show and he's gonna win probably
because he's putting on such a great
show and people like a great show I do
think I'm now of among the people who
think something new we're witnessing
we're witnessing something new with
Trump it's not just the same old thing
where the process is so onerous that
it's selecting for the kind of
narcissist or you know thick-skinned
person who is willing to submit to the
process and then there are many most of
the good people just will aren't going
to put up with this I mean yes there's
that too but there's um there's
something there's him it's a moment
among the electorate where it's like
it's a funnel it's an anti aesthetic
there's an ant is enough of an
anti-establishment mood and and vote now
is it happening with with Sanders to
where people just want to jam a stick in
the wheel of the system just to see what
happens just like we this is what
the main gripe against Hillary really is
that she's politics as usual she's not
going to change the system
right right people want to change the
system but they're not really thinking
about the implications of radically
changing the system and in the case of
Trump I mean here is someone who is who
is advertising his lack of
qualifications for the office in every
way that he can it's like he like there
is no I mean I'm not even but I'm not
even bothered by his racism or his
misogyny or his demagoguery or his bully
I mean all of that I'm willing to to
guess is an act right that he's decided
that that's somehow pandering to his
base and he's actually in truth he
doesn't have a racist bone in his body
say I'm willing to it to believe that I
matter I don't know why I would think
that's plausible but it's it's it's a
you know I have a hunch that he's far
more liberal than he seems
and it's just pandering but the thing
that that can't be true is there's no
way he's actually brilliant and
well-informed about all the issues and
is saying the things he's saying he's
not pretending to be as uninformed and
is incoherent and as irresponsible as
he's seeming because you wouldn't
withhold information it did make you a
better leader well it's just it's yeah
it's just it was just the vacuous nosov
is speech it's like he's he'll say that
he'll say the same thing three times in
a row and it was meaningless the first
time right he'll say it's going to be
amazing it's going to be very very
amazing trust me it's going to be so
amazing and he does this with everything
if you look at the transcripts of his
speeches and the fact that he can't he
has never I mean so far as I've seen he
has never once strung together a string
of sentences that was even interesting
right but he bit like he's knit he's
never he just there's never a moment
where I record or I say oh this guy is
smarter and better informed than I
realized that that moment
never comes I keep expecting to see that
happen and it's a little bit like mad is
this image of like you imagine have an
urn right where and you just you keep
pulling things out of it and all you
pull out of it is chunk right you pull
you know chicken bones and broken
marbles and gum and and it's it's still
possible that you that if you root
around in that urn long enough you're
going to find the Hope Diamond I mean in
each round that you pull something out
that really has no logical implication
for the next thing you might pull out of
the urn
but mines aren't like that when I see
what this guy says he does not say
anything that a well-informed
intelligent person would say and it's
just and ideas are connected right so
you can't just you can't fake this stuff
you can't say you can't fake being this
this uninformed and you can't fake being
really well-informed and he's just me
just let me look at one policy that he
wants the the in the rounding up of
illegal aliens right around up 11
million illegal aliens now this this
gets stated as yeah we're going to round
them up and send them back to Mexico and
what worries me is no one seems to care
but that if you just look at the
implications of doing this it is that
this one policy claim alone is so
impractical and unethical
it's just what are we talking about here
you're talking like you're your gardener
your housekeeper the person who works at
the car wash the person who picks the
vegetables who that you buy in the
market is going to get a knocking on the
door in the middle of the night by the
Gestapo and get sent back to the zoo
the vast majority these people are
law-abiding people are just working at
jobs that that Americans by and large
don't want to do and many of them have
kids who are American citizens right so
I'm absolutely someone's got kids under
the age of 10 who are American citizens
and what you guys send that person back
to Mexico and you're going to do this by
the hundreds of thousands and millions
it's just that one point alone held in
isolation from all of the other things
he said the crazy things like climate
change is a
folks we've concocted by the Chinese to
destroy our manufacturing base and you
know the fact that he likes Putin I mean
everything else he said right this one
policy claim alone should be enough to
disqualify a person's candidacy it's so
crazy but the moment you you look at it
and yet no one seems to care in fact
it's just it's just more energizing to
the people who already like him I know
that he said that he wanted to build a
wall but I didn't know that somebody
wanted to get rid of the illegal aliens
rounded up and around him up and do want
with him I'll send them back to their
goal is so crazy that's such a crazy
idea and it's so brutal the idea that I
mean it's like it's a subhuman thing the
only reason why people would come to
America is because they felt they felt
like it would make their life better so
people take a big risk it's not there's
not an easy way to do it if you're poor
you don't have any qualifications for
any unusual job I mean you're trying to
get across to Mexico but everybody who
does it does it because they want to
improve their life you know and the idea
that one group of people shouldn't be
able to do it one group should just
because they were born on the right side
of some strange line that is only a
couple hundred years old but but I
actually now go further in meeting him
in the middle where is it so it so I
think we should be able to defend our
borders right so it is I don't have a
good argument for having a porous border
that we can't figure out how to defend
and we don't know who's coming into the
country right so I think building the
wall is almost certainly a stupid idea
among his many stupid ideas but it I
think it would be great to know who's
coming in the country and have a a
purely legal process by which that
happened I mean ultimately that's got to
be the goal right right and we are we're
imperfectly doing that and so I don't
have an argument for open borders or
porous borders but if the question is
what do you do with 11 or 12 million
people who are already here doing jobs
we want them to do that help our society
and the vast majority of them are
law-abiding people who as you say are
just trying to have better lives the
idea that you're going to break up
families and send people back by the
Mille
and the idea that you're going to devote
your law enforcement resources to doing
this when you have real terrorism and
real crime to to deal with it's just
pure insanity right and and and also
totally unethical and yet he doesn't get
any points docked for this aspiration
and it it's just it's one of the things
around which people are rallying but the
climate change thing is also insane and
dangerous well here's a birther right
yeah right he was one of the original
birthers he was saying that Obama's
birth certificate was he was
born in Kenya right wasn't he one of
those guys oh yeah he was he was some I
would like funding that for a while yeah
I would love if he got in the office and
just said listen folks I am nothing like
this person I pretended to be to win the
presidency I just wanted to show you
that you've been manipulated and get it
together and he just punked all so I'm
gonna hire some people who actually know
how to run things and we'll see that's
the the the smart people who are voting
for him think and this is I think it
actually a crazy position but that they
think that he is just pandering to the
idiots who he needs to pander to to get
into office so he's he's not disavowing
the white supremacist votes you know
with the the alacrity that you would if
you were a decent human being and you
found out that David dukes who supported
you because he needs to he just he needs
those votes and he knows that that most
of the people in his base aren't going
to care and he can just kind of move on
in the in the news cycle and he's doing
this on all these issues where he look
we're smart people see that he looks
like a buffoon and they are treating him
as a the people who don't like him are
treating him is a comic figure who he
can't really believe that stuff he's not
really he's too sophisticated to really
believe that stuff so he's just
pandering I mean one is it people aren't
seen if that's true
just how unethical and weird that is
right who the guy has no compunction
about lying and demonizing people cycle
let's say he let's say he thinks that
that Clinton really isn't guilty but
Bill Clinton isn't really guilty of a
rape right and now he's calling him a
rapist right now at the time he was
saying he wasn't a rapist and he's just
being defamed and this is outrage as he
was saying he was taking the side of a
friend who you know he invited to his
wedding but now he's he's calling him a
rapist right a sexual predator who's
harmed women's rights more than anyone
so which is true right so there's
there's no version of the truth here
that makes Trump look at all acceptable
as a person is like either he knew he
was a rapist and was defending him
because he was just cozying up to power
at that point right didn't care that
he's a rapist or now he he knows he
still is still the guy who thinks he
wasn't a rapist but now he's just for
purely opportunistic reasons he's he's
willing to call a guy rapists who he
knows isn't they're both horrible right
and it's not like this new evidence has
come forward in the intervening years
that it would have changed his mind
about what happened in Clinton's
presidency so he's some but I think
people think that he's got to be much
more sophisticated than he is and that
if he got into office he would just be a
totally sober and presidential person
there's no reason to believe that I mean
if he thinks climate change is a hoax
and that we should pull out of the Paris
Accords and we should ramp up coal
production and bring back the coal jobs
and this is what he's saying right
there's no reason to think he doesn't
believe this at this point that's just
it you know it is a disastrous thing for
a president to think the only
fascinating versions of this that I've
been hearing from people that I respect
are that the idea that he is like the
political version of the asteroid that
killed the dinosaurs like he's going to
come down and smash it and it's going to
be so chaotic that they're going to be
forced to reform the system and people
are going to respond in turn like the
way people are responding against
factory farming and more people are
going vegan
that kind of a thing they're going to
see it and they can respond in turn that
is such a so so he's going to toss the
applecart up in the air he's just going
to this whole goofy system up and
then we'll be able to rebuild after
Trump has dismantled all the all the
different special interest groups and
lobbyists and all the people that we
really would like to get out of the
system we really don't like the the fact
that there's such insane amounts of
influence that big corporations and
lobbyists have had on the weight loss
get past the myth this might be the way
to do it you have some wild man you
everyone's fired you have fired you're
fired Jetson it's like a character like
he's coming in his hairs plastic he's
all fired up he's a billionaire and made
all his own money sort of dad gave some
money but he turned into a lot of money
point being he doesn't need anybody's
money truth is he's probably lying about
the amount of money he has to it is his
but he's a baller for sure though right
at the very least he's got to be worth
some cash yeah I'm a there could be a
big difference between what he's
claiming when we got back true but he's
he's a minute there are many pieces here
I mean people assume that because he's a
successful businessman he must
understand the economy right which was
no necessary connection there right
there's a lot of rich people who are
totally confused about economics and you
know most economists don't have a lot of
money so there's not even no real
connection there but the the I mean so
what you're describing is a kind of just
random like like you're just let's just
let's just smash the window yeah and
then see what happens right look I'm
going to light a fire to this this place
and and see what happens and that's it
almost any process by which you would
change the system is more intelligent
than that mm-hmm you know and yeah and
it's also not valuing how much harm it
one bad president could do right like
there's no I think even I haven't tested
this but I'm imagining that even Trump
supporters would answer this question
the way I would hope which is like if I
had a crystal ball they could tell you
we can't tell you who's going to be
President but it tells you how it works
out for the next president so like right
I look in this crystal ball and it says
the next president United States is a
disaster right just it's like the worst
president we've ever had you just think
of you know just just failures of
governance and and the toxic influence
of narcissism and hubris that comes
along just like once every thousand
years right justjust a disaster I think
you know even if you're a trump
supporter which candidate that was like
only Trump is is likely to screw things
up that badly it's not Clinton is going
to is going to be almost perfectly
predictable she's going to be a
politician she's gonna she's going to be
basically centrist on a lot of the on
foreign policy and domestic policy you
know she's going to be liberal on social
issues she is not going to try to be a
dismantle NATO and to get into a war
with North Korea or you know get into an
alliance with Putin or image she's not
going to do something insane and the
alliance with Putin yeah he he said
basically only favorable things about
Putin their homes yeah they're tight so
we should get yet hopefully we'll see
pictures with both of them on horseback
shirtless and I have to go read the I'll
be able to you shirt on I hope probably
keep your shirt on I don't see him as
being the shirtless guy yeah no I yeah
when when just look at the landscape the
between Bernie and Hillary in him and
you know to me it looks like the last
gasps of a dying system sorry but that's
representative government system but it
is a lot of a lot of people are saying
that you things like that but they're
not hearing just how nihilistic that is
if true right right like like we there's
so much stuff we have to get right right
and there's so much and and the only
tool to get it right is having your your
mind actually understand what's going on
in the world and
how to manipulate the world in the
direction you want it to go so you have
to understand like whether or not
climate change is true your beliefs
about it have to be representative of
that truth right so like let's say you
know let's say it's let's say I'm
mistaken and there's you know there is
no human caused climate change it's not
a problem and every moment spent
thinking about it worrying about it
correcting for it is just a waste of
time that's just throwing out you know
the wealth of the world right that would
be a terrible thing right so it really
matters who's right about that and and
the fact that we have a president or a
candidate who is coming in saying this
is all you know in defiance of
all of the science is and it's it's true
but it's on every other part of a
problem doesn't know anything about you
know I guarantee you he doesn't know the
difference between Sunni and Shia Islam
or which countries are Sunni
predominantly in which or Shia
prominently and I'm sure he's going to
do I don't know when he's going to cram
for this final exam I'm sure before one
of those debates he's going to get you
know someone's gonna sit down with him
and give him some bullet points he's got
to have in his head but his head is just
not in this game it's never been in this
game it's obvious from everything he
says and that's what that is something
you can't say about Clinton right for
all of her flaws as a person I don't
care how much you hate her as a person
she understands what's going on in the
world right and that's that difference
is so enormous forget about all the the
other character flaws of this guy who
who was just obviously going to I mean
he's but are we attached too much to
this idea of one person being the
figurehead figurehead someone has to eat
right I'm one decider if we all woke up
today if everybody woke up and there was
just no government it was nothing well
I'll just what happened I don't know but
we got to figure out how to run this
thing well we had no no previous
understanding of government what do you
think anybody would say we need one dude
to just run this whole giant continent
filled with 300 million people most
likely if we woke up and we had
technology like we have today we
ability to communicate like we have
today with social media and whatever we
would probably say we need to like
figure this out amongst each other and
find the people that are the most
qualified for each one of these
positions and start running our
government that way well that that's
what we're attempting to do but it's
just and I totally agree with you that
it is astonishing that out of a nation
of 300 million people these are the
choices yeah you would think you would
think we starting from your your base at
your zero setpoint of just you know now
we're going to reboot civilization you
would think that if you had this kind of
process each candidate would be more
impressive than the next me what you'd
be like I can't believe I eat each
person who came to the podium likely so
so on James oh yeah it'd be light you'd
be like the dunk contest you know for
the NBA I'd be like oh my god like it's
just just when you thought you saw the
best dunk in your life the next guy
comes along exactly and it would be that
it would be that on every topic right
would be like you'd be talking about the
science of climate change you'd be
talking about the the the actual
dynamics of the war on terror - it's a
topics that that seem had to have no
relationship where you would have to be
you'd be amazed that anyone could be an
expert in all of them you would find
someone who was an expert a functional
expert in all of them a jeopardy winner
dude yeah yeah but so and but someone
who is also ethically wise who doesn't
just wasn't obviously an right
um
and who who had a mature relationship to
changing his or her mind
right so like that this whole bit about
flip-flopping and and not you know being
caught it like this is someone who could
honestly represent changes of mind in
you know across a political career right
this is there's no it's nowhere written
that it's a good thing to believe today
what you believe twenty years ago in
fact they do that on every topic it
means basically you haven't been in
dialogue with the world but there's
something it's so taboo to change your
mind that either you have to lie about
it or you have to pretend it was a you
is always that way or
it's just a an assistant yeah the the
the the system is is broken in that
respect but given the choices you know
and when you have a choice between
someone who is for all her flaws been in
the game for long enough to be really
well informed and capable of compromise
and capable of not just just breaking
the entire machine and you have someone
who's just he just got stepped off the
set of his reality TV show and then lied
about everything and a an elbowed his
way you know
onto your television set and never left
because you know CNN couldn't figure out
how to give the mic to someone else it's
it's amazing well he's a product of
attention because they realized that
there's a the heated race right the
heated race this guy was really famous
and in a heated race this guy would say
some crazy stuff and so they would tune
in to him so everybody had to tune in to
him so because of him saying crazy stuff
he accelerated the amount they were
talking about him so they're constantly
talking about him and barely talking
about other people and but he's created
a wormhole in our political process now
where there's nothing so crazy that
could disqualify him among the people
who like him that so he can just keep
like nuclear bombs of craziness that the
press can't ignore that the every time
they think okay this is the crazy thing
he said that's going to harm his
candidacy so let's shine a light on it
it just helps him you know he could just
he could you know he could need to get
on Twitter right now so you know who I'd
like to I'd like to Nicki
Minaj and and it would work for him it
would hurt for me you would see a you
would see a tweet storm of a billion
people who say I'd like to Nicki
Minaj to go get her and it's insanity
that's where we are
but in a sense if we do admit this is a
up system it's not ideal it
should definitely be reworked and it's
so hard to rework wasn't the best way to
rework it a Trump asteroid just slams
right into the White House
boom blows the whole thing sky-high who
knows what terrible things have to
happen but maybe that would be enough
thing is we have those those asteroids
are coming anyway so when you look at
like 9/11 was an asteroid right so it's
like a or a superbug that that becomes a
pandemic that these are things that are
coming and we need people who are in
touch with with reality to deal with
them right so it's like what the moment
someone it advertises their not only
their ignorance but the fact that they
don't care that they're ignorant and
they do that this again and again they
keep doubling down that person is like
if you put that person at the helm what
you have done is basically put chaos at
the helm right it's like like this
person's going to believe whatever he
believes regardless of the information
coming in and regardless of the
consequences that's just I mean it's
it's it's worse than having no one in
charge and because you're you've put the
power in this person's hands right so
this but this person is everything has
to go through this node in the network
this is just like an information
scrambling device right so like know-how
Matt no matter how good the information
is coming in you have everything that
you've got a bottleneck here which just
screws up the signal right that's what
you're doing if you're if you're if
you're hiring someone like this who I
mean yet in the best case you're what
you stated earlier would in fact be true
which I he'll get into the Oval Office
and even he will be scared about of the
prospect that he's now running a better
part of human civilization and he will
hire the best people or some semblance
of the best people he can get access to
and say tell me how to not screw this up
and and that will be and then it'll then
it'll essentially be business as usual
right you
so far as you've hired that the best
people will be people people who are are
deeply in this game already right you
know it will defer to the generals when
it comes time to make war being real
really pragmatic about how they pick
politicians and how they push certain
people and decide not to push others do
you think that something like Trump
completely changes how they move forward
now they realize that this can happen
like now that you see that people are so
goofy we're so WWE doubt that you can
get this guy you know I mean this is
this is where we're at where we've got a
guys I told him the wall just got 10
foot higher yeah everybody gets crazy
like how could you say that yeah once
they realize that that's possible how
long before you get like some
motivational speaker type dudes how long
before they start jumping in there how
it Tony Robbins Ted president so we
that's what we have I mean that's this
is well this is way worse than Tony
Robbins for president Weiwei was all
positive dude yeah yeah but I vote for
him yeah no Tony right positive god no
that's not what I mean I mean right but
that sort of ability to excite people
right like if we could get like one of
those motivational speaker dudes like
most guys who wears a lot of yoga pants
and he's gonna he's gonna be the next
president he's gonna get us in shape
it's gonna be a reality show America is
a reality show we're there we're awesome
we're the best
did you see this press conference he
held I think was yesterday no I didn't
know that was a very funny moment where
the prayer there was one journalist I
didn't recognize who it was who gets
hooked so so Trump was being very
combative with the the press pool and he
was he was basically you know shouting
them down not answering any of the
questions and one journalist just a gas
said is this what it's going to be like
when you're president is this how is
this how what it's going to be like to
be in the White House press corps and
deal with you and and he said yes this
is what this is exactly was going to be
like and but you could just see that
like the journalists like they turn the
camera on the room a journalist and they
like they are astonished by what is
happening here like they don't know
they're participating in this process
and in some sense they have created this
process
but is this no not all of you just many
of your fine enough of us is this what
you do is it is this what its gonna be
like covering you if you're president
yeah it is let me do you have this kind
about the teachers restroom okay yeah it
is gonna be like this David if the press
writes false stories like they did with
this because you know proud half of you
are amazed that I raised all of this
money if the press writes for starters
like they did where I wanted to keep a
low profile I didn't want the credit for
raising all this money for the vets I
wasn't looking for the credit and by the
way more money is coming in I wasn't
looking for the credit but I had no
choice but to do this because the press
was saying I didn't raise any money for
them not only did I raise it much of it
was given a long time ago and there is a
vetting process and I think you
understand that but when I raised almost
6 million dollars and probably in the
end will raise more than 6 because more
is going to come in and is coming in but
when I raise 5.6 million as of today
more is coming in and I and this is
going to phenomenal groups and I have
many of these people vetting the people
that are getting the money and would you
play at the moment I was referring to I
mean so here is a case where he's
probably almost certainly lying about
his history of giving to Veterans
Affairs and he gave money very recently
after people started fishing around to
see if he actually had given the money
that he claimed to have given to to
veterans but I mean this is the what's
difficult about this is that I mean the
pret yes there are the press is highly
imperfect and there and also partisan
and there are false stories and there
are you know exaggerations and that they
screw people over yes and there are
reasons to not trust the press from time
to time but I mean the in this case you
have a someone who there is no amount of
fact-checking and dis confirmation of
his statements that that forces him to
ever acknowledge anything that he's done
wrong and the lack of
knowledge meant - he pays no price for
it among among the people who like him
and so the press is powerless and then
and then but the net result of like a
press conference like this if you were a
Trump's follower is he just showed how
biased and and petty the press pool is
and the press do need to just be beaten
up by a strong man who who's not going
to stand for their
but it's a it's a maybe what it son
becoming at the very least that kind of
communication it's kind of unexpected at
sprit II mild you know that's why me
compared to his League his paradeen of
the of the disabled reporter who he saw
that bit where he you know did like a
cerebral palsy imitation at one of his
speeches he was - yeah oh yeah yeah he
was interviewed by I don't happen to
know who them and it was a reporter was
oh he was making he was making fun of
somebody with cerebral palsy I mean sir
he's done so many things that you could
that you would think would be
fundamentally cancelling of a person's
political aspirations like like you
can't you caught Marco Rubio pretending
to be like a just goofy on someone
cerebral palsy at at one of his campaign
events Oh be the end right yeah one of
the things that some Ted Cruz was just
that video with him with his family the
outtakes well they were I did it oh you
didn't see it no it's a gem uh-huh it's
spectacular it's him with his mom and
he's like my mom prays for me often for
hours every day and she like right she
looks I'm like what the you talking
about for hours every day no i don'ti
can't even say that and so they have all
these really awkward moments like okay
I'm gonna go in for a hug I'm gonna say
I love you it's all like weirdly mapped
out and that got online and people were
like oh Christ
okay I see that this is this is a bad
game like you're not even good at this
game this is you're terrible at this
game yeah he was objectively terrible
well that's his that's Trump's
competition well the thing that would
think about Cruz that never even got out
which was the reason to be scared about
a Cruz presidency was his level of
religious craziness I mean no one was
even pushing on that because it was just
enough to push on before he even got to
that door yeah you have to hold on to
those weapons yeah but I mean had it
been a crew had crews been the nominee
it would have been all about religion
what's what's odd is that that's not a
handicap in 2016 that you can have that
and people consider it an asset well the
one thing that's surprising and actually
hopeful in Trump's candidacy is the fact
that he has he has dissected out the
religious social conservative component
of the Republican Party so like the the
evangelicals for the most part we're
going for Trump over Cruz when it was
pretty clear to them that Trump was just
pretending to be religious and I mean so
it's a Trump gave one speech at you know
I think Liberty University where he
spoke he said you know Corinthians 2 and
you know that's not the way any Bible
reader would would speak about the
second Corinthians how would you say 2nd
Corinthians
that's what how you would say yeah yeah
and so he said he said Corinthians 2 is
like MO as though this is something he
just opened every every night before he
went to sleep and so it's clear that it
was clear to them that he's not that he
is just just miming the language you
know or impersonating a person of faith
and but they don't care really as long
as he does it and that's that is you
know if you're gonna look for a silver
lining to this it it shows that it's not
it's is they just want a space where
their religious convictions are not
under attack
and they don't really care that the
person in charge share them just you
just if you pretend to share them that's
good enough and that's that's better
than actually caring that this person
really believe in the rapture or
anything else that is quite obviously
crazy
but yet so I don't think any Christian
who's voting for Trump thinks I mean
they'll say I'm not going to judge
another man's faith right or I'm who am
I to say what's really in his heart
right they'll say that but he's just
given a the if you if you've been paying
attention to who he's been and and if
you just look at how he talks about
these things I don't he's fooling any
any Christian that it so I think they're
willing to vote for someone for now for
other reasons that are fairly depressing
in their own right they're willing to to
vote for someone who's who doesn't
really play the game the way they do you
have to believe in God to be president
in 2016 right when you wouldn't you say
that has to pretend to believe in God
yeah but I think with Trump I think it I
think his the pretense is is obvious
enough that I don't think he's fooling
the better part of the people who were
voting for him who would say they care
about a person of faith being in the
White House so anything he might be in
one thing he might be breaking is the
barrier on having an atheist president
because I think he you know it's just no
but nobody thinks he is a person of
faith I don't think anyone really thinks
that so so he's he's me might be our
first atheist president he would help us
in that in that regard as well another
Trump meteor right into the White House
yeah I'm starting to sound like a trump
supporter occasionally an asteroid does
something good who would be the ideal
president I mean like what what kind of
a person who I mean it would probably a
person who doesn't seek attention
probably a person that well I don't they
it could be that I mean the PERT that
the process is even even an optimized
process will be well we're cool it will
require enough sacrifice of what
ordinary people want most of the time
that it will be an unusual personality
who has to get promoted you will be on
some metric B I mean it's almost by
definition narcissistic to think that
you should be in this role right right
who are you
to think that you should be running the
civilization at this moment in human
history and to for you to be on it's for
you to honestly stand at the podium and
say I'm the guy you know or the woman I
am the most qualified I should be doing
this right I can help you know if you if
you're going to scrutinize the kind of
personality that could give rise to
those opinions it's not yeah there's
there are some dials you would probably
want to change tweak if you if you had
to be married to this person or if it's
not an optimal personality so there's
going to be there's a kind of pathology
of a power seeking that might be just
intrinsic to it but you want someone who
is actually wise ethically I mean just
just just try to map that onto Trump
right just he's imagine someone saying
thing I like about Trump is that he is
so deeply ethical and wise right it's
just it does not I mean it's like saying
it's because his hair looks so natural
yeah is I mean there's just no it is the
antithesis of what he is right the thing
I like about Trump is that he is so well
informed about the way the world works
and where he's not informed he
recognizes his ignorance so quickly and
he remedies it as fast as possible he
did you know he seeks out the best
experts defers to them and you know he's
just he's as mindful of the limits of
his knowledge SEO as he is about his
expertise and his expertise is vast
right you'd want to be able to say that
about a president you could not begin to
say that about Trump right you could
probably say that honestly you could
probably say that about Clinton right
like Italy yeah for all her defects
she's very knowledgeable and I'm sure
she will just try it where she'd up
where she doesn't feel like she's got
the knowledge he's going to try to go to
go to the source of the knowledge right
just grab the best expert she can find
I think she I think she will be as aware
as you or I would be of the consequences
of not knowing what's going on right
she's just going to want to find out
what's going on
whereas this I mean all Trump has
advertised about himself is that he
thinks that bluster and banality and
bullying will win in every situation
just like it's just attitude he the guy
is the guy is winging it and it could
not be more obvious that I that this guy
is winging it on every level and it's
like it's just it is it is it's not
there'd be no way for him to signal the
fact that he's winging it more clearly
than he is what everything he's doing
and and yet there's no penalty do you
think it's possible that in this age of
information the way we can communicate
with each other that we're going to
experience these cycles these waves
these in and outs these high and low
tides of really smart presidents and a
really stupid president and we just
people revolt and there's just it's so
easy to stay alive is plenteous to
people out there and so they're only
willing to vote for other dumb folks so
the other dumb folks get into position
they send out the frequency that only
the dummies here and everybody else is
going what the is everybody voting
for this guy for what is happening and
then it makes the smart people rebound
and four years and challenge themselves
anew because they they need some sort of
an enemy to rally against to reach their
full potential and then without the low
tide you cannot have the high it's a
virus that's hopefully that's not an
analogy that applies the maintenance of
civilizations the smell yeah yeah I know
the time man maybe well at the very
least it's a wake-up call for the
political establishment this silly game
you've been running of two candidates
just doesn't work
someone can co-opt your candidacy get in
there throw the monkey wrench
into the gear system and guess what
Trump's running for president now is
that he's the head I mean he's the head
guy for the Republicans how is that even
possible they don't know it what's
amazing it is a way if nothing else
a total wake-up call for the Republicans
may are just it's June a cast yeah it's
June everything's decided locked down so
we have July August September October
November we're that close but if he's
not someone who has been who's aligned
with the Republican platform in most
ways right so it's like he's been the
truth is virtually no one knows what
what his policies are because he keeps
changing his position on things like
taxation it's like if there actually is
no he said he's talked on both sides of
a core issue core Republican issues but
I mean in many ways he's left of Hillary
right he's you know he's left of Hillary
in terms of being an isolationist like
he's you know he means his his
relationship to war is but both extremes
like he's like no we're just kind of
we're going to get out of the world's
business right we're going to be
isolationist which is deeply
anti-republican but I'm going to be the
maniac who you're never going to know
who I'm going to bomb next right when
we're going to wipe out Isis we're just
straight away right did not not a man
left standing and I'm not going to take
any from anyone including China and
North Korea and so he's that but we're
gonna pull back in a huge way and not be
in anyone's business right he said both
of those things it's it's it was way too
interested in a way it may we don't want
politics to be this interesting and it's
going to be me November is going to be
if the polls are closed and watching
those debates and and and waiting for a
swing in the polls as a result it's just
going to be it's going to be way too
interesting it's gonna be like watching
the Super Bowl
those first debates you know it's going
to be it'll be a hundred million people
watching those debates I have a
prediction
I think I think it's entirely possible
this whole thing was a plot that didn't
work out this I think he probably came
out of the gate saying crazy
thinking he would tank the Republican
Party and get his friend Hillary Clinton
into the White House
no just didn't well she didn't work out
he kept trying to insult her kept trying
to make stuff up about Mexicans it just
kept making him get better and better
and now he's stuck he can't pull out hey
that that would be that would be a great
moment that would change the system well
we're going to have to go through
something like this in order for us to
realize that this is crazy that a guy
can just do this can just not really
have any interest in politics until hold
out then he should get the Nobel Prize
for everything if he pulls out at this
point and says listen I'm just took you
to the precipice here just because I
want you to recognize how unstable this
situation is you you guys could elect a
demagogue who is actually an incoherent
demagogue and I haven't even been
playing an incoherent authoritarian
right I'm I'm on one hand a very liberal
right and tolerant and on the other hand
I'm like getting ready to be Hitler and
you guys can't figure out who I am and
yet you're still prepared to vote for me
right I mean yeah for him to do a
post-mortem on on his punking of the
culture that would be the best thing to
ever happen but I don't think that's
that's what's happened do we need
someone like this so that we realize how
silly this whole thing is do we need
someone like that no we need a qualified
person to deal with all of the other
hassles and dangers that are coming our
way that have nothing to do with with
what we do right like what that verse is
not that even even if we were doing
everything perfectly there would still
be the tsunami of risk right and hassle
and waste and just omit all the rest of
the world's chaos that is coming our way
and it's just
even if we had our house in order in
every respect
we still have terrorism and the you know
global climate change will you have that
you've got China and India and what are
they doing in terms of complying with
with climate goals you have all the
things we've been talking about you know
the the virtual certainty that there's
going to be a pandemic at the not what
I'm talking about bioterrorism we're
talking about just the sheer fact that
in 1918 there was a killer flu and
there's going to be another killer flu
right there's just no way there's not
gonna be another killer flu and we need
we need people and we need people people
to smart people to change to optimize
the system to deal with these kinds of
things and if we're promoting you know
religious maniacs and and crazy
narcissists and liars and ignoramus and
only that those people how could this
end we'll this is just a weird year for
like heavyweight boxing you know they
have those weird years for heavyweight
boxing when Tony Allen is a champ and
and then are you where you could be the
heavyweight champion they went through a
period of time in like the early 80s for
Tyson came around was a series of like
these champs that were like you know
sort of like journeyman fighters and
then Tyson came along maybe that's what
it only only with heavyweights right
yeah mostly with heavyweights yeah the
lighter weights they were always badass
but I think that maybe that's what's
going on maybe we need to have this bad
season get the season out of our way
realize the danger of having an inept
person in office whether it's a liar or
dude who hates money or or Trump whoever
it is just go through it and realize how
silly it is that we have it set up this
way still